i'm here with professor lawrence baker
from stanford medical school and i'm
hoping he can at least start to get me
to understand something that i've always
worried wondered about and and worried
about a little bit let's say that i'm
i'm some drug company so let me write
this down so like i'm i'm some pharma
company pharma
pharma company a right over here and
let's say that i i don't know i invest i
invest 10 years and 100 million dollars
in in in some drug i get it through all
the clinical trials and it gets approved
by the fda and it is and let's say just
for sake of simplicity it cures
it cures
it cures disease
it cures disease x
now once i get to that point i'm feeling
pretty good about myself i'm as the
pharma company
what happens next i mean i'm assuming
that i'm going to have to go to the
insurance companies and maybe medicaid
and medicare and figure out how much
they're going to pay for it but how does
that conversation even happen
yeah so you're going to have a
conversation with a bunch of different
uh folks so in the us we have lots of
different private insurance plans we got
government plans and you're actually
going to have conversations with europe
and with some of the other systems
around the world because each system is
going to make its own and they have a
different way of doing it
they may not they they are having some
similarities in the way that they
probably want to talk to you about does
there tend to be a lead system does it
tend to be either the europeans or does
it tend to be the private insurers in
the u.s or do you start all those
conversations at once because there's so
much money on the table so there will be
some strategy your business is going to
come to it's very hard to have all these
conversations exactly simultaneously so
you'll talk to the us you talk to europe
and some there are some cases in which
people have viewed the regulatory
processes in europe as a little easier
for some things so they might want to
start in europe but in other cases if
you're looking at a drug that maybe some
of the national systems in europe are
less likely to want to pay for you might
start with the us where there's a little
more flexibility and but the general
rule of thumb is all of the money is in
europe and the us mainly right now a lot
of it's there the asian systems and some
of them are uh pretty sophisticated and
and using a lot of the advanced drugs
too but i think the majority of the
money's in us right and between europe
and the us i guess i've always imagined
it was a lot north america was was maybe
where the bulk of the money was but is
that the case the u.s um well our health
care system spends more than everybody
in the world and it's true for drugs too
we spend more on drugs here than okay so
definitely if i'm here pharma company a
i mean i i want to make sure i get this
right in the u.s yeah eventually you
probably care a lot part of my
investment that i've made is based on
some understanding that i'm if if i got
all the way through that i would get
some type of return within the u.s so
let's say i go to i go to the will i
necessarily go to immediately go to
medicare because they're one of the
largest players or will i go to like we
talked about blue cross blue shield or
kaiser or some of these other players um
so you probably medicare is actually
kind of an interesting one for drug
prices because historically medicare has
not been a big
cover and still isn't of a lot of the
the drugs that you hear about so
medicare does not pay
by itself for outpatient drugs drugs
that you might take at home really i
always assume that they they don't they
don't so medicare in its main pieces
medicare we call part a part b part c um
so part a and part b let's go start
there they tend not to cover or they
don't cover outpatient drugs if you get
a drug in the hospital while you're
while you're hospitalized medicare will
pay for those and so if you've got a
drug that's going to be primarily used
in that
setting you're going to talk to medicare
about it and that's going to be an
important piece of the conversation but
if you're talking about an outpatient
drug
you're talking to many people say
outpatient i mean inpatient is you're in
the hospital you're sick you need i
don't know morphine right now that's
inpatient drug yeah outpatient is hey
you're going back home take this three
times a day yeah somebody sends you the
pharmacy to pick up the prescription and
you take it home with you that's going
to be an outpatient
drug so medicare doesn't cover that in
its main part a and part b there's
medicare part d which is a drug plan in
medicare
and that will cover a lot of the
outpatient drugs and so there you have
conversations with with them but most of
the medicare part d plans are
essentially private companies
uh that medicare contracts with so
you're not really talking to the
government at that point you're talking
to these private plans that have
contracted with medicare
so once again going back to the the crux
of the question of
how are these drugs gonna get paid for
how we're gonna determine the price at
which these drugs get paid for it goes
straight it goes back to the private
plans again because they're going to
contract their part d is going to say oh
your medicare part d we're going to go
to we're going to go to aetna we're
going to go to some other plan or
whoever it might be i don't know whoever
is offering those whoever is offering
those part d plans and so it'll be it'll
kind of ride off of whatever that
private party has already negotiated
with the pharma company be related
probably okay so let's say let's say i
go to let's say that so we have some
type of insurance let's call this
insurance i'm running out of letters now
let's call this insurance company
insurance company y right over here and
i go have a conversation with insurance
company y and i was like hey this is a
big deal you know disease x you know
it's it's been killing people
i want one million dollars per pill
yeah and so those have been really
interesting conversations in the u.s so
there's some uh bargaining back and
forth between the insurance company and
the drug maker the drug maker is going
to have spent a lot of money you've got
100 million up there yes in most cases i
deserve to make at least 10 billion
dollars off
so there's a certain certain amount
certain extent called anchoring in a
negotiation
right you start with what you think you
can yes yes
the number to get everybody's mind
around right yeah um so you know in
reality it costs well over 100 million
to take a drug through the trials to do
the development work and stuff so
they're going to be sitting there with a
number at least internally saying we
want to get our 800 million our 1.5
billion back from this and so we're
going because it's not just the cost of
that one drug is that you so what is the
cost you do for the top of the room
hundreds of millions just so there's the
development costs that go in that the
pharma companies aren't typically
willing to talk a lot about right and
then there's the cost of getting through
the trials and the fda approvals which
people say you know 500 million and up
they'll say higher numbers
for one for one given drug yeah 500
million so so it can be as high as 500
million it can be higher can be
greater than 500 500 million and so that
doesn't even take into kind of the
probability weighted risk that there's a
ten percent chance that it fails or a
ten percent chance that it works right
so it's really if if you're spending a
hundred million per drug and only one
out of ten of those drugs are going to
get to the to the end zone
yeah you'll see we're actually spending
and you won't spend the whole wide
and then find out you'll find out inside
right you'll have to stop something to
get there so even though this on one
drug it might be 100 million or 500
million they might have spent another
300 or 400 million on drugs that didn't
go anywhere plus their own development
costs plus their own development cost so
so if you if you try to kind of fully
load the cost it's it's a it's a large
number it's a large scale yeah so
they're they're running a right exactly
they're running a operation they've got
to put a lot of money in up front when
they get a success they have to get
enough out of that one success to pay
for the operation right to kind of keep
things going for the next development
round so they're looking at those kinds
of numbers and they're trying to figure
out in this negotiation what they can
sell this for and that's a back and
forth discussion insurance companies
have some ability to you know say what
they're willing to pay but um a lot of
these drugs if they're doing a curing
disease people care about the the pharma
companies have a lot of
ability to come and say this is what we
need to get for this and set that price
and be able to get it for a while so who
has i mean obviously the pharma company
is coming here with all of this
investment they definitely want it to
get covered but the insurance company i
guess their incentive is they don't want
to look like all of a sudden this this
company that doesn't provide a you know
the cure for disease x i mean do
insurance companies ever walk away and
say well you know that's just too much i
understand you invested all this money
but we just can't do that that's just
crazy so the uh it's a little bit of a
mixed bag the us doesn't have a lot of
cases where insurance companies have
really put their foot down and said no
they're not going to do anything they're
not going to have anything to do with
some new drug that comes out and some of
that's the fact that due to the
existence of lots of different companies
so right you know if five of the
companies say no but the next guy in
line says yes then the
dynamic of that in a competitive market
is often that everybody else will
eventually come around and say right you
know someone's going to do something
they might not they might not pay for it
outright that's why you know i guess the
whole reason we're having this
conversation is because there's some
drugs that are you know seem like
reasonably priced to me but there's some
that are like
thirty thousand dollars a pill or
something i made up that number but yeah
so if you so the cases the really
expensive ones are drugs that are uh
unique uh
tend to be unique at least to some
extent cure a disease that gets some
high profile so people are worried that
they're going to die if they don't get
this drug uh and of course they're still
on patent that's another feature of this
right you get this we get the high price
for a certain period of time until your
patents run it and then the generic and
then generic companies and the price
cost of the pill which is great drops
pennies are dollars right right um so
you know how you get these things set in
a competitive market is an interesting
question one of the things that happens
um
one of the things that gets the brand
name drugs to be a little cheaper is
competition within the class so if
there's two or three drug manufacturers
you have something that'll basically do
the same thing that'll tend to take the
edge off or 30 000 a pill kind of
situation and get you down reasonable
more reasonable prices it won't get you
all the way to generic pricing but it
just seems to me i mean you just
mentioned that very few insurance
companies have ever walked away from
this if if you ever have a negotiation
you know buying a used car whatever
where one of the two parties is not
walking away then it doesn't seem like
there's actually a hard a serious
negotiation am i getting that wrong or
is yeah so you know i got i don't know
all the ins and outs of all these right
right there's lots that goes on in these
things but i think that one of the
things that people would say about the
us is that
when a manufacturer drug manufacturer
comes up with a fairly unique on-patent
drug that does some tangible good that
they more or less can set the price that
they want to get for it and they're
going to make some calculation because
they could set a high enough price that
everybody would say forget it so they're
going to try and figure out something
right but they're trying to get as much
as they can and they get
some leeway for at least a period of
time so they'll get leeway and i guess
there's some range of of reasonableness
where it's like okay yes you're you know
you've done something amazing for
humanity
you you're gonna get a you know a 30
return on your investment but that
shouldn't be a 300 return on your
investment yeah i don't you know i don't
know at what point the u.s would ever
walk or the private insurance so we
don't ever walk from this i haven't seen
it really happen and i think drug
companies are pretty sophisticated about
trying to figure out what price they
think they can make work and get that as
high as they can get there yeah so i
guess i'm still back where it's still
unclear to see who who's kind of making
out here really well
you know this has been a really
interesting debate you know pharma
companies put huge amounts of money into
these drugs and once in a while they do
some really useful things and they get
high premiums there are other people who
argue that some of the things that
they're getting high premiums for you
know aren't
really valuable enough or somehow we've
been told we need a drug that if we had
it to our own devices we would never
come up with the fact that we needed and
so you know what's the real value at the
end of the day and i think that's one of
the debates we're going to have in this
country for a little while the industry
has been coming up with new things and
they're going to keep trying to do it
right um
we want to from a social standpoint from
a policy standpoint try to make sure the
things we're doing are really valuable
to society and not copies of other drugs
or not inventing a disease that didn't
need a solution and then solving the
problem and sometimes we worry that
maybe we're getting some of that and i
think that's the challenge for the us
health insurance system for the
regulatory processes to try to guide the
innovation and guide the purchasing of
these things to really create the most
value for society it's been a challenge
it's going to be a challenge we we have
the challenge because we have tremendous
opportunity
so your good sense there probably are
some drugs out there that maybe we are
that that the the the they're doing
really well
maybe
well above and beyond the investment
cost but it's hard to say it's not
really on a case-by-case basis
yeah i don't think you'd want to make a
generic statement about all the drugs
that have been discovered some of the
things that we've put out there in the
last couple decades are really important
drugs are going to do a lot of good and
you know i think there are debates about
some other ones where maybe somebody's
been able to be clever about marketing
and sell it and we're less sure that and
then actually marketing not to make this
conversation too long uh but but you
know some people bring up the drug
companies you know they say look there's
a lot of investment right over here on
on this and so they have to get some
reasonable return on it and that seems
to make sense especially when you
probability weight and all of that
but they spend a significant amount on
marketing as well on actual marketing
you watch the nightly news you're
getting most of the ads you're going to
see the drug companies they do the
physician dinners and they do all their
things like that i mean that seems to
undermine that argument that all of the
money is going for for r d
right if you just towed up the dollars
i'm not sure how uh you'd actually what
the numbers would come out like and it's
you know honestly the pharmaceutical
companies aren't really excited about
telling everybody all the details about
businesses for good reason right uh so
it seems like it's absolutely there's a
huge amount of money you spend a ton of
money on the marketing and then you get
you know you get the consumer here to
kind of put the pressure on the
insurance companies and the doctors to
say hey you you better cover that or i'm
asking for that or whatever it might be
yeah there was a time uh you know within
my memory where we weren't allowed to do
direct-to-consumer marketing where the
laws prohibited that and the change came
around and now we're allowed to do it
and it's really changed the way the
drugs have been i have found that weird
because if these are drugs that are
meant to be by prescription
and it should so which means that it
should be a doctor's judgment on whether
or not you should get the drugs why is
it being advertised on the nightly news
to a general audience right right
general audience who doesn't understand
all the ins and outs of the drug and
whose doctor
may or may not want to take the time to
then then they'll go exactly but then
they'll go to the doctor and say please
give me this drug and then the doctor
it's easier for them to say sure yeah
now i think i think a lot of doctors
would express a certain amount of
frustration about that their patients
come in it's hard to have the
conversation in a short period of time
so it's easier just to give them the
drug fascinating